par les uns oubliés par les autres on
pourrait penser que le poisson pané
congelé avait disparu au contraire il
s'est refaite une beauté et plus présent
que jamais là maintenant on vient
séduire le consommateur qui se définit
un peu comme un foody aventureux on
vient de séduire avec des recettes
différentes avec des ingrédients qui
sont un petit peu plus recherchés qui
lui donnent un peu l'impression de
voyager avec son bâtonnet de poisson je
vais essayer de faire en sorte que même
dans une allée où c'est foi ben vous
allez voir vous tirer le bras et mettre
le produit dans votre panier on a donné
rendez-vous à notre spécialiste en
marketing dans la section la plus calme
d'une épicerie là où les gens ne
traînent pas sur un plan historique
c'est une section qui est fascinante
parce que à la sortie de la deuxième
guerre mondiale faut savoir que on avait
des rations sur certaines denrées le
port le bœuf etc mais le poisson n'était
pas assujetti au même politique de
rationnement alors ça n'en a fait un
ingrédient assez pratique pour les
manufacturiers on a des ingrédients
quand même assez recherchés pour jardin
qui dit pratique dit succès c'est
vraiment une des grandes tendances
présentement dans l'agroalimentaire on
veut des ingrédients bons frais
savoureux mais pratique et puis on vient
essayer de trouver des nouvelles
recettes des nouvelles façons de séduire
le consommateur avec des mots clés avec
des labels de certification on ajoute
des saveurs qui sont par exemple le plus
à l'italienne aérotif Finder de citron
et poivre noir c'est vraiment plus
savoir international notre
nutritionniste a analysé une centaine de
produits qui affichent maintenant
pratiquement tous la provenance du
poisson auparavant on avait plutôt des
produits traditionnels mais aujourd'hui
on ajoute toutes sortes de saveurs à
ceux différentes formes il y a des
bâtonnets à des croquettes des burgers
donc c'est clairement de la variété moi
ce que je vois c'est que l'industrie a
beaucoup travaillé à essayer de
démontrer leur souci de d'approvision
démontrer qu'ils font à faire avec des
entreprises de pêcherie durables
maintenant je pense qu'on est rendu à
améliorer la liste des ingrédients
de ce côté-là et je pense que on a
encore beaucoup de travail à faire ça
c'est certain
fabriquer exclusivement à partir de
poissons blancs comme l'aiglefin la sole
la morue et la goberge le poisson pané
est tout simplement un filet de poisson
enrobé du chapelure dans la majorité des
produits qu'on retrouve ce sont les
mêmes ingrédients de base donc c'est un
peu comme on le ferait même à la maison
c'est à dire que de la farine un liquide
avec de la chapelure dans les produits
qui sont plus transformés qui vont
servir à faire des croquettes des
burgers on va plutôt miser sur la
goberge c'est un produit qui est moins
coûteux je vois ici pâtes à la bière
parmesan et poivre citronnés donc là on
est dans une recherche de saveur
d'expérience gustatives il a ça c'est
mon préféré
de poisson qui ont des hommes et ici on
vient jouer encore une fois ou même
titre que le bâtonnet de poisson a joué
sur le format hot-dog donc un référent
culturel ici on vient jouer sur le
format L2 poulet l de poisson et ça mais
c'est vraiment du finger food on va le
faire lorsqu'on voit accueillir des amis
par exemple mais attention elle rime
avec celle de façon générale les
produits comme ça qui sont assaisonnés
très transformés ils sont très salés là
on parle de plus de 700 mg de sodium par
portion
on a mis au défi un professeur de l'idhq
et ses étudiants de choisir leur
préférée parmi 6 produits du moins au
plus salés
pour des jeunes enfants c'est trop
piquant je pense le produit qui est le
plus traditionnel le poisson et la
panneau c'est souvent ceux-là dans
lesquels il y a moins d'additifs je
trouve que c'est la plus belle panure à
mon goût panure à l'anglaise je trouve
que votre
c'est quand même fade mais la texture la
panure est bien le poisson est
reconnaissable donc on dirait c'est
vraiment on dirait un morceau de filet
ça vous prédire que c'est dans les
produits qui ont retenu pour les bonnes
raisons votre attention oui donc ici on
a les filets de morue sauvages panés le
choix du président et les filets
d'aiglefin écossais menu bleu donc dans
les deux produits qui avaient la
meilleure teneur en protéines et le
moins de sodium le par portion
entre guillemets donc ça c'est comme pas
très amalgamé
de semoule qui a été déposé sur le
poisson les deux bâtonnets de poissons
aiglefin et sol eux avaient une teneur
en protéines vont intéressant sauf qu'il
y avait moins de sodium donc ça je
trouvais que c'était un produit là qui
était relativement bien des bâtonnets de
poisson c'est souvent ça qu'on va offrir
aux enfants avec un petit peu de ketchup
le public cible les enfants sont
contents ça se prend comme une frite
et il y avait un artefact des
de notre époque je pense qu'il y a un
public pour ça mais vraiment on peut
faire mieux
le produit ce sont aussi des marqués
pour leur teneur raisonnable en sodium
pour les autres produits attention
il y a beaucoup plus de saveurs c'est un
bon ratio de pâtes poisson aussi mais
moi mon seul bémol c'est qu'on dirait
que ça goûte un peu moins bon pour la
santé oui
c'est ça qui était le plus marquant dans
les produits c'est même s'ils ont une
teneur en protéines qui est relativement
adéquate le sel c'est très très élevé
dans de l'eau salée pour se gorger
carrément il recrache ce qu'on lui a
fait un gérer mais le parmesan je l'ai
pas goûté du tout le prix maintenant et
ce produit abordable
on a fait le comparable avec des filets
d'aiglefin par exemple qu'on achèterait
frais à l'épicerie il y a de la
manipulation en usine d'autres
ingrédients ajoutés donc c'est sûr que
ça augmente le coût par contre pour les
produits qui sont les plus riches en
protéines puis ça fait partie de nos
deux meilleurs choix ce que je constate
c'est que étant donné qu'il y a une
belle quantité de protéines moins de
panure à l'intérieur ça reste très
similaire pour ces deux produits là donc
je pense que c'est une belle alternative
c'est pas évident de cuisiner un poisson
blanc donc d'aller chercher ça ça peut
être une bonne façon de faire aimer le
poisson par exemple à ses enfants ou à
d'autres membres de la famille si on le
sert avec des légumes rôtis puis du
quinoa à côté mais ça reste que on a
quand même un repas qui a une belle
valeur nutritive dans son ensemble et je
pense pas qu'il faut se culpabiliser
d'aller chercher ça pour la faciliter la
rapidité
[Musique]